え、まって
7プレイもできるの？
チョウス
はじめしゃちょーです
ぼくはよく知らないんですけど
え、取れるんでしょ
取れると噂のあるマシンのあるメディアがあるので
やっていきたいと思います。
はい、こちら
キラキラ　アソボックス
緑より当たりやすい
高確率赤くじ投
入中
これっしょ
赤いのとればいいの？
カプセルを取ったら
当たるし
まじか
カプセルを狙わなくても
このくじを取るだけで
ひょっとしたら
当たりがでるかもしれない
という
わけでございます
それでは当たりの商品はこちらです
え～
特賞とかやばいね
ほしいねプレステ4
apple iPod touch 16GB
ホームベーカリー
1等が結構すごいね
PSVITA
ディスニーチケット1DAYパスポート
ペアーですね～
あと、任天堂3DS
で、
2等がこんな感じです。。。
まあ、1等狙いかな～
その感じだと
で、
3等
パイの実
やった事ないんですけど
当たるって聞いてたんで
たぶん、まじで
もうすぐ行けるわけじゃないすか
もう
ぽろっていってぽろっといけばすぐ落ちると思うんで
1等か2等にしよう
1等か2等が出るまでやります
何等出たの？
俺は200円で2等
まじ
200円で？
カプセルの中に入ってた
ま～とりあえず
様子見でやってみましょう
ひとまず、玉狙いでしょ
カプセル狙いで行きましょう
こ、これ取りますわ
ほい
え、すごい
え、
そんな早いの？
これは？
あ、OK、はい
OK
いきます
あ、
あ、まじやべえ
きたきたきたきたｗｗｗｗ
あ、あ、ああう
マジで取れるのこれ？
普通のさ、このさ
普通のくじをねらっていくよ
OK,OK,OK
やべ！！
落ちた！　落ちた！落ちた！
まって！
気づいたら　3つぐらい落ちてたんだけど
地道に狙うよ　ちょっと
こいよ
さすがにとれよ
OK OK！　OK
いいよ　いいよ　いいよ！
OK　OK OK!
いきます
OK！
地道に稼いでいく作戦で
5回やったところ3つ取れました
でも赤はいいんでしょ
はずれ
やる気がツキを連れてくるんだ
はい
少し足そうよ粘り気を
はっ！！
面倒くさいとはずれます
たくさん取って
だっ！！
ホントにこれ当たるの？
ボール取りたいんだよね
1回、気合で
は　は　は、は！！
まって、　まって、まって！！
えええええ、、
今、やばくなかった？
え、じょあ　もう
あれ狙っていきますは　もう
重心をずらしたほうが
取れる気がした
あ、　きたきたきた！
OK oK!
そのまま　そのまま
きたきたきた　きた！！
やばいやばいやばい！！
どこどこどこ
ここか
ｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗｗ
でも、こっからすよ
じゃあ
次、もう1個この玉狙うね
もう　玉。狙おう
おお、　きた　きた！
お、あ！
10回やったところですね赤いのが2つになりました
で、次はこれさえ落としちゃえば
落ちる気がします
もう1回あった
あ、　きたんじゃない　これ
完全にきてるじゃん
きてる、　きてる　、きてる　！！！
完全にきてる　完全にきてる
まって、まって
まって
え
こっちを
見ないでくれないかな
ほら　OK
7回　7回！
くじで押し出そう
くじで押すしかないよね
OK　じゃあ
赤いくじを狙っていきます
比較的
お、お、お
OK OK OKよ　OKよ
ウィ～～
GO!
ねえ
意外と近くのほうがみんなとってないからさ～
ほら
ほらね
お、きた
落ちた！　落ちた　落ちた！
落ちた
くじ落ちたよ　1個
あ、あ、あ、！！
え、めっちゃ落ちてるんだけど
ほらほら
あ！
ん、ン、ん　ん　ん　ん　ん～～
あ、あ
え、でもさ
落ちるよ、もう
数の暴力で
カプセルもうやばいもん
いこいこ
違う
何か1個でも
と、取るだけでいいから
しっかりつかんで
そう
おいおい
OKOK
あ！
お！
赤カプセルだな
ここ狙っていこう
ね
カプセルはすぐ落ちたんですけど
そっからすね
勝負はこっからの気がする
けっこう落ちてる
31回分いきます
あ、あ、、あ　！
ちがう
うわぁ！
ちがわい
あ、　そう　あ～～
あ、　待って　待って　待って　待って
見て見て見てみて
ほらほらほらほら
あるよ
取り出しますよ
なんか、奥に赤い玉が
埋まってたんで
それを掘り出します
違う
そのまま　持ってき～～
あ、　ずれた
は、　待って
今
こうにもなってなかった？
あ　ほほほほほ！！
落ちた　落ちた　落ちた
え、待って
WWWWWWWWW（笑）
なんかわからないけど玉取れました
もう1PLAY　あるんで
絶対これさーー
あ
なんか　やばい
落ちたもん完全に
三角のパーツがとれちゃったWWW
ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ
ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ　ぺ
一応とれた分はこれくらいでございます
赤カプセルも取れたので
ひょっとしたら、この中に1等が入っているかもしれない
ということで
開けていきましょう
いきます
はい！！
緊張だな
開けます
緑だよ
緊張してきたな
開けます
はい！！
おおおおお！！
2等じゃん
え、ェ、ェ、ェ、ェ、ェ、ェ、ェ、
よし
無事、2等の商品手にはいりました